lo que haremos en este vídeo es realizar
algunos ejemplos para ordenar números
que tienen decimales digamos que tenemos
los números 1.001 0.1 13 y 1.101 lo que
quiero hacer es ordenar estos números de
menor a mayor
tomen un pedazo de papel y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos vamos a resolverlo la
manera que yo utilizo para ordenar
números es que primero me fijo en el
número que está en la posición de mayor
valor y que todos los números tienen en
común en este ejemplo está la posición
de las unidades en todos estos números
podemos ver que este tiene una unidad
este tiene 0 unidades y este otro tiene
una unidad el número que tiene menos
unidades será el menor de estos números
este de aquí es el menor de estos
números voy a escribirlo por acá 0.1 13
ahora tenemos que ver cuál es el que
sigue entre 1.001 y
y 1.101 pues analizamos el siguiente
valor posicional
es decir la posición de las décimas
vemos que son iguales en la posición de
las unidades pero si vemos la posición
de las décimas este tiene cero décimas y
este otro tiene una décima por lo que el
número a la derecha es mayor porque
tiene más décimas tienen el mismo número
de unidades pero tiene más décimas no
importa que hay a la derecha de esto así
que el siguiente número menor al ordenar
de menor a mayor
es 1.001 y por último pero no menos
importante está este número que es el
más grande 1.101 hagamos otro ejemplo
ahora tenemos los números 0.4 240.3 43 y
0.4 43 pausa en el vídeo y traten de
ordenarlos de menor a mayor por su
cuenta
la idea es nuevamente siempre comenzar
en la posición de mayor valor compararlo
y después continuar a la derecha si es
que algunos valores
vamos a resolverlo juntos todos los
números tienen ser unidades todos son
iguales en este valor posicional lo que
no nos dice mucho ahora analicemos la
posición de las décimas aquí hay cuatro
décimas acá hay tres décimas y acá hay
cuatro décimas sólo hay que analizar el
lugar de las décimas o las centésimas
este tiene la menor cantidad de décimas
por lo que es el menor de los tres
números 0.3 43 ya usamos esta ahora
debemos comparar estos dos números que
tienen el mismo número de unidades y el
mismo número de décimas por lo que ahora
analizamos las centésimas éste tiene dos
centésimas y este otro tiene cuatro
centésimas este tiene menos centésimas
que este otro por lo que el de la
izquierda es el siguiente número menor
0.4 24 y por último pero no menos
importante está el mayor de todos tiene
el mismo número de unidades que nosotros
tiene más décimas que el número de en
medio
y el mismo número de décimas que el de
la izquierda pero también tiene más
centésimas que el de la izquierda por lo
que este número es el mayor de todos 0.4
43 y terminamos